it is an Easter like no other for our
troops overseas
military chaplains coming up with unique
ways to mark this holy day safely
including drive-up communion right after
the live-streamed mass at a u.s. post in
japan joining us now the man behind that
idea a lieutenant colonel Donna Oki
chaplain for the US Army Garrison at
Camp Zama in Japan chaplain good morning
thanks so much for doing this we saw
what you were doing or who's not our
viewers would love yes happy Easter to
you we thought our viewers would love to
hear what you are doing for our troops
overseas on this Easter Sunday yes we're
doing some remarkable things some
creative things doing things a little
differently than we normally do but the
communities really responded well to it
you mentioned the drive-up Communion our
Catholic priest father Irizarry he came
up with that idea and because it's so
important to receive Communion and at
first I thought the I laughed and then I
thought well that's just crazy enough to
work
and really just how inspired and indeed
the communities responded well the cars
lined up every Sunday after Mass they
stay in their vehicles and they are all
able to receive Communion they receive
the blessing from father Irizarry and
also our Protestant folks are also doing
the same thing as well it's just a
matter of thinking creatively thinking
differently we don't have a game plan we
can fall upon from last year it's just
people coming up with good ideas and
implementing those ideas and taking
taking advantage of what there is still
available for us to do even as we are
practicing social distancing chaplain
what is the troop morale throughout all
of this
our morale is really high our folks are
100% behind leadership and people
understand exactly what they need to do
to keep themselves safe and more
importantly also to keep one another
safe this is a community effort it's
very collaborative and
people have kept their spirits high
sometimes it's really difficult to
especially see the news from back in the
states I don't think there is any family
here that is not impacted by what's
happening in America but yet we keep our
hopes high we're very resilient and we
stay strong it's a very positive message
and something wonderful to hear on this
Easter morning chaplain and we've been
showing pictures there of camp zama and
and the services that have been going on
these drive up services and even little
Easter bags were there to hand out so
you pull up in your car just like the
drive-in movie and you tune into the
station there and you hear this service
and you go away with your Easterner bag
leave us off with the response that
you've been getting to all this it's
been fantastic people really responded
well they loved it they loved the idea
for those of us who remember drive-ins
yes it has that feel of people drove up
they cut their Easter bag that
volunteers put together and we made sure
was was done with great care to make
sure we didn't spread the virus if it's
not done very carefully and they tuned
in to FM 88.9 and were able to hear us
through the transmitter and stayed
together in with one another inside
their guitars but still together as a
community as well it's so important to
keep even as we're practicing social
distancing that we still have that sense
of community is still there and I think
people really have the responses they
really felt like they had an opportunity
to worship together as a group even as
we were separate in our cars and giving
it over the radio there is a sense of
belonging and togetherness that we so
long for and it's so important for us as
a part of our faith to practice chaplain
aqui you're also the tenant Colonel
Donald aqui we thank you for your
service thank you for everything that
you're doing for our troops and for the
community there to keep their their
spirits high during these difficult
times Thank You chaplain thank your God
bless